Hey traders, it's Mike here and in this
video I'll be talking about the order
flow exhaustion entry model. And you
know, a question that I've been getting
a lot is do I just trade every single
sign of exhaustion? No, you don't,
right? And as you can see on today's
chart, you know, there were there were a
few here which didn't work. You got one
that's just starting to work right here.
This one was a small winner. This one
also a small winner. This one was a nice
20-point winner. This one just sort of
went sideways. I'm going to discuss, you
know, what made this one so nice, this
one nice,
this one, you know, why you might not
want to take it and why these you
probably wouldn't take as well as these
you probably shouldn't be taking. All
right, so let's let's jump into it here.
So let me just get the footprint up.
Okay, so you know, today is Monday the
18th of May and
Okay, so cash opened right around here.
Started selling off, then we rallied all
the way up to new highs. This was a nice
uh you know, over over a nice 20-point
rally up into those new highs. And right
off the bat we kicked off an exhaustion
print here and exhaustion print here.
This one, this first one, okay, you
know, again, you know, cash just opened
right here, started selling off. You
know, we got the nice negative deltas
here, minus 50, minus 600, minus 280.
Then it turns positive, 219, 268. Boom,
you get your exhaustion print here, 42,
even got the bullish ratio. Okay.
What happens? Nothing in the next bar.
Next bar goes inside, right? That's not
a good sign right off the bat when
you're looking for this market to start
rallying, right? You want to see price
start to trade up. We do eventually take
out this high by one tick
a couple bars later, second bar.
And then what happens? We just trade
sideways for the next, you know, what? 1
2 3 4 basically 5 6
seven bars before we break down and we
get this exhaustion print.
Now,
is this a bad trade to take?
Well, I I I would honestly I would like
this this bar to start going up, not
open up and then trade down. That's not
a good sign. It's nice to see this bar's
point of control holding. Okay, then the
next bar comes back up and it looks
like, "Hey, you know what? Maybe we are
going to start a rally. Maybe there's
just a little bit of selling pressure
left over." You know, this bar's got a
nice positive delta 335, but it goes up
and then it pulls back, right? We got
this big
I'm sorry, this big upper wick and this
the lower um
sort of a smaller candle just below it,
okay? So, it it's not a good sign.
Again, you know, it it's one of those
trades you're looking for a potential
reversal off of the low from when the
cash just opened, right? It's not the
low of the day, but it's the low from
when the cash opened.
Maybe we could get a a bit of reversal,
but then once it starts going sideways
for the next 5 minutes,
it's probably not going to happen,
right? As the best moves are the ones
that start going up, go up up up. Okay,
so again, you know, even if you took
this trade, you know, maybe you got
long, I don't know what that would be
around 29 and a half, you know, you're
going to get stopped out down here,
uh wherever that is, 20
23. Okay?
You
start the day out with a loss. Okay,
fine. Just wait for the next trade.
Boom. You get your next
exhaustion print here, five.
And this bar, okay, it's it's got a lot
of nice things going for it, right? We
even have a nice uh
POC towards the bottom part of the bar.
And we got this order flow value area
absorption. That's why this
value area is colored blue, right? I I
have some videos. Uh one of my A+ setups
is the bullish value area absorption
that's not traded into in the next bar.
It actually trades on the second bar
here and then you see it hold and then
we also rally. So now what we have
actually is we got exhaustion print
coming in with the bar with the value
area absorption. Okay, so you got two
nice bullish things coming in at the
swing low.
Right, this next bar does trade up by
one tick, pulls back, okay. Then the
next bar opens up, heads down a little
bit and then rallies up. You got some
nice
very thin volume on the counter trade
here, a zero and a three. You know, but
you should already be long off of this
red candle, but if you're not, you know,
you're probably getting long somewhere
around 26, 27.
And then over the next 10 minutes it
rallies all the way up
above 50.
Okay, even goes
Whoops, even goes a bit
even goes a bit higher here. Um
gets all the way up to 54 and a quarter
before it starts selling off. Okay, and
once it starts selling off, what do we
got?
We got another exhaustion print here,
right? This high up here doesn't have
any exhaustion print, but this low does.
Now, the only thing I don't like about
this bar is it's kind of big, right? It
goes from basically 25 all the way up to
about 40. So it's a 15-point bar. Okay,
it's kind of big. And I said the reason
I don't I'm not a
I don't love this bar is because the
market's already moved 15 points. Okay,
how much more can it go? You know, so it
goes from 7440, gets up to, you know,
this high over here is like what, 47 and
a half? This one here is about 47.
So you just got to keep that in mind,
right? Usually these elongated bars, you
know, it it's using up a lot of energy
to get to those
get to those levels. Okay. Um you know,
it even pokes up here to around 48
before it comes back down. Now, a couple
things to keep in mind, right, when
you're looking at exhaustion prints.
Again, when you you like sort of the key
is being able to identify swing highs
and swing lows cuz people say, "Well,
you got an exhaustion print here. You
got an exhaustion print here. Should I
have taken these?" Well, okay, start
with this this one here. Okay, yeah,
it's nice you got the bullish
value area absorption, but it is traded
into in the next bar.
But again, is this a swing low? Well,
you know, we're talking this bar came in
at 9:15
and you know, not even 10 minutes
earlier we were we were trading that
level right in here just as this red bar
with this exhaustion print here, is this
a swing high?
Well, you know,
one bar, two bars, three, four, five,
six, seven, eight, nine, 10,
you know, 11, maybe 12. So, not even 15
minutes have passed in between here and
here this bar
and where we were trading there earlier,
right? It's you know, I also like to
have, you know,
a clean swing high or or a clean clean
swing low. At least this one here does
have a bit more space,
you know, from when you traded. It's
definitely more than 15 minutes. Okay,
so again, you know,
do you have to even take this one? Not
not really.
Um but again, you know, there's a little
bit to be had, but this one definitely I
wouldn't consider that a swing low and
this one I I probably definitely
wouldn't consider a swing high even
though it is a lower high and this is a
higher low, but you know, there's not
enough
uh time has um
passed, you know, as opposed to here,
right? Cash open, obviously that I would
take that as the the start of the day
and you have these two coming down, you
know, this one obviously there's nothing
to the left, this one nothing to the
left. You even have this level from
overnight, this previous value area
absorption where we trade back down into
it. Okay?
Now,
a bit later,
get over here.
Um
you you start to see a little bit more
exhaustion come in. Okay?
Here.
And this one, it's not bad.
It's decent. You get a nice spot
10-point move off of it. You know, you
have market is selling off and again,
it's selling off from a much higher
level, about uh you know, 20 to to 30
ticks cuz this
this is 7440. This price right here is
7410. So, we just had a 30-point move
down. Okay? So, you do get some
exhaustion forming in there,
which is nice. You know, the delta 653
302 382, then it turns a nice positive
400, follows up with another nice
positive 140, which is nice to see.
Okay? So, it was a it was a very strong
move down. So, you're looking for a
reversal. Okay? It's just the only thing
that sort of has me a little bit
hesitant is this yellow line here.
Okay? And what this yellow line
represents, and I have the the day's
high, the day's low, but I also look at
the day's open. Okay? And you know, even
though today's Monday and we open Sunday
night, you know, often times, you know,
barring any um
major news over the weekend, you know,
just as you would from the session close
to a session reopen,
um you know, if there's if we're s-
in the middle, not well, this is like
9:30
9:50 this morning. We're trading at
basically where we opened, essentially
unchanged. And we know that when the
market is trading unchanged, there's a
lack of catalyst in the market. Now, you
know, we got a lot of stuff going on.
Trump was in China.
Um
Got a lot of stuff going on in the
Middle East right now.
We're trading it unchanged. So
basically,
traders are are trying to decipher or
not decipher, but waiting for the next
important piece of information coming
into the market. Okay, so there's not
much of a catalyst. So to see this move,
even though it was it was a move from
around 74 say 13 up to um you know,
about 26, you know, it was it was a
smaller move. That's because traders are
basically waiting for something
to hit the market. And what I mean by
waiting for something is I I mean a
catalyst, something that will tell them,
"Hey, to get long or get short." You
know, change their position overall.
So, I'm not saying that this is not a
trade to take, but
if you don't take it, I'm fine with that
simply because
you know, we're trading at unchanged or
we're trading at where we opened,
meaning nothing's happening. I mean, and
and think about it, right? You you turn
on the TV, right? You flip on CNBC or
Bloomberg, and you first thing you do is
check, "What's the market doing?"
And if you see it, you know, around
unchanged, you know, you know, plus
point 01%
basically nothing, you know there's
nothing happening in the market. So, why
would you be taking a trade when nothing
is happening in the market?
Right? I mean, you you can, but again,
you know, you're sort of limiting your
your potential for profit. And over
here, again, you know, look at this
yellow line is is key. This is to me
sort of the the line to say just stay
out, right? Here you got two. You got an
exhaustion print. Here you got a one.
You know, it's trading at basically
unchanged, right? There's nothing in the
market. So, if you're waiting for a move
to happen,
you could be waiting for a while, right?
And and look at when this
you know, here it's 10. We you have this
uh
10 11.
You know, this is going back to you
know, 9:30 so you know, 45 minutes we're
still trading at unchanged.
And then we're just sort of rotating
around. Okay, rotating rotating around.
Um,
you get a couple exhaustion prints here.
Right here.
Again, but it's just right on the line
basically literally the bars trading
there. You get another one here. Now
this one's a little bit more interesting
because you do have
the bearish value area exhaustion uh
value area absorption
plus the exhaustion prints. So you got
absorption plus exhaustion which is a
strong signal similar to that bullish
one that we had early. But again, we're
right on this line. Now we do get a
we do get a move you know, 74 11 down to
you know, this was about uh 01 right in
here. So it's it's a 10-point move does
pull back goes down to 74 double O. But
again,
do you want to be trading in an area
where the market is consolidating when
the market is trying to decide you know,
should we be putting in a move or not?
Okay, and I just don't think it's very
effective to be trading around
unchanged. Now on this
you know, on on the bar chart right?
Just
glancing at it you can see
all right? This yellow line is unchanged
and this is just a simple NinjaTrader
tool that anyone can get you know, if if
we're trading the bar
is right on the line right on the line
right on the line right on the line.
This one's just it's not on the line,
but it's right above it. Okay, do you
want to be taking those? No.
No.
No. I mean, you know, you could have the
best signals in the world like you could
go into the mountains for 6 months and
come out with, you know, your your
trading system. But, if we're trading at
unchanged or we're in an area of
consolidation, it's not going to be very
effective. At least this one here, here,
here, you know, we are coming down.
We're well off this level, which, right?
If we're trading above it, it's going to
be acting as support. Just as if, you
know, we're trading below it and then we
were to come back up, we'd be looking
for it as resistance.
Okay? People always ask, you know, hey,
what's a good level I should be
watching? Always watch the low of the
day, the high of the day, and basically
the opening, or if you want, you can
watch the closing price from Friday.
Okay? So,
you know,
those are
reasons in and of themselves not to take
this trade,
these two trades, even these two trades,
right? You What you want to be is coming
down to a level,
looking for exhaustion,
exhaustion.
Okay? This one is about a 61.8%
pullback here. But again, you know, it's
not the biggest move, but I think this
one is is definitely worth taking, maybe
for a run back up towards the high of
the day. Doesn't quite get there, just
sort of goes sideways, but again, at
some point,
right? Even if you're if you're long in
one of these two bars,
you know, if you just see the market is
going nowhere for the next 15 minutes,
you don't have to wait for it to come
stop you out. You know, after about 15
minutes, you know, for me it's about 10
minutes,
if the trade's not really moving,
it's time to get out.
All right? The best trades are the ones
that take off right away when you're
looking at the order flow.
Okay? Now, you know, just
a quick aside note, um
in the
bonds today, okay? The
Right here, at the high of the day. This
this was fascinating, especially when
you're looking at bonds and then the
tens. So, I I always love this. We're at
the high of the day,
trades a thousand contracts on the offer
here. Second time, you got less volume,
trades 10. To me, that's a nice bearish
sign. So, you got your exhaustion here.
You've got your bearish
value area absorption. I'm not surprised
to see this market have a nice sell-off,
you know, from around the 27 area all
the way down to 17. That that's a nice
10 ticks,
um
within about an hour,
okay?
But what again, you know, what I wanted
to talk about that that was so
fascinating about this is relative to
the 10-year. So, this is the uh ZB,
right? The 30-year bond. The ZN, whoops.
Uh
the ZN, okay? So, here, just really
quick. Again, the volume, right? Just
watch this.
I It was 1,000 and then 10, so it was a
lot less the second time, okay?
Now,
ZN actually had the opposite. Now, we
know there's a lot of arbitrage that
goes on between um
tens and and 30 years,
but I I just found this fascinating to
to see just sort of geeking out about
it.
Um yeah, it's sort of the opposite
effect, 242
and then 1,400. So, you know, there's
there's a lot of liquidity up here,
right? You can just see the volume that
went through, 18,000
on the bid, 15,000 on the offer. And
again, you know, we had just been
trading there just over an hour earlier.
So, we sold off, came back up here, and
at these levels,
big liquidity up here.
Okay? Now, you don't have the sign of
absorption that you did have
the bearish sign of absorption that you
had earlier, as well as having it on the
bonds.
Okay?
But again, similar type of move down.
You know, but I thought the bond
the read in the bonds
was much easier to read.
I mean, to me that that was just like
classic textbook example right here.
The exhaustion print value area
absorption, this double top, and the
nice move down.
All right, guys. So, I hope that uh
helps you guys out looking for
the order flow exhaustion entry model.
Right? I mean, again, you know, you just
got to keep it simple when reading the
order flow. A lot of times, traders get
so caught up
when they first come to a footprint
chart thinking, "Oh my gosh, you know, I
got to look at all these volumes, all
these numbers. I hate math, you know."
You're not doing any math.
You're just looking for the lack of
activity,
the lack of trading activity, which
translates through the volume, cuz these
are all the the volumes that trade on
the bid
or the offer.
And
if it's coupled with a nice sign of
absorption,
it's a beautiful trade.
Okay?
So, thanks, guys, and I'll see you guys
on my next video.